hello from Devils the question I decided
to try to respond to is is unemployment
rising because technology is replacing
labor well first of all if you look at
the technology sector I think it's a
right to say that that's where most of
the new jobs have been created in the
last 15 or 15 years easily also second
acting in poisons communication and
advertising all the new jobs that we are
creating are those linked to social
media and the use of a new technology so
I I do think that yes of course robots
exist and they do replace jobs in
factories but they also to create much
better jobs actually and which add a lot
more value in many other areas so I'm
very optimistic about the fact that it's
about education and making sure people
can use this technology is the real
issue thank you